well the Academy has leaned left for a
long time but in many schools that tilt
is becoming monolithic utterly
monolithic a new report looked at the
faculty at more than 50 top liberal arts
colleges and found that if the service
academies are excluded Air Force Navy
Army registered Democrats outnumber
registered Republicans more than 12 to
one and much more than 12 to one on some
campuses the higher up the food chain
you go the more unbalanced it becomes
this lack of ideological diversity is
breeding arrogance among other things
say some gerard alexander is the
political science professor at the
University of Virginia in
Charlottesville he just wrote a great
piece for the New York Times over the
weekend warning liberals you're not as
smart as you think George Alexander
Cooper special thanks are coming on
thank you for having me so what do you
mean by that liberals you're not as
smart as you think as every writer knows
they don't choose their own titles and I
might have preferred something a little
bit less clickbait e'er aggressive but I
just was I was trying to communicate to
liberals who I think many of whom mean
well for the country and don't realize
some of the effects they're having
that's their tone their approach to a
lot of our national conversations about
a whole slew of issues can it can
attract and persuade people that giving
a speech from an Oscar stage giving a
lecture on a campus using all kinds of
you know the platforms that they have in
American life
the prominence they have in American
life there are times when that can be
used to set an example to educate to
attract to lend celebrity and
credibility to points of view but it's
distressing to me how often those
platforms end up being used in ways that
communicate a self-righteousness
communicate a tone of intellectual and
moral superiority how often they're used
to berate instead of to persuade and I
think one of the effects liberals don't
realize they're having is how much
they're alienating other people I think
it's almost entirely inadvertent and I
think it's one of many trends in
American life that's really unhelpful
that we could better avoid and I try to
give him the article an idea of ways
that they might try to avoid doing that
diversity was supposed to be the
guardrail that prevented people from
going off into self-righteousness and
lack of self awareness having people
around who do
with you who bring different life
experiences to the conversation was
supposed to broaden us if in most
universities there's nobody who doesn't
agree with you you never meet anybody
with a different view why wouldn't you
become arrogant and dumb over time as
they have it's it's a serious problem
you know liberals have been such great
forces in modern American life for
bringing certain kinds of diversity to
the table and being enthusiasts about
that and who doesn't think America
hasn't you know has benefited from more
african-american faces more Hispanic
voices more women in prominent positions
America has benefited intellectually in
other ways from that but they really
have had a blind spot when it comes to
what some people I admire greatly have
started calling viewpoint diversity may
be better than ideological diversity and
academic wait a second what I don't what
what's the point of ethnic or gender
diversity if not to bring viewpoint
diversity actually that was the point
how can one how could how can it like in
other words if you have a group of
people who all look different but come
from the same culture and have the same
views how is that in any sense diverse
well originally they didn't come from
the same viewpoints people who came from
the Jim Crow South had very different
life experiences than upper middle-class
northerners but increasingly what
happened especially through American
universities is a trend towards gender
and ethnic diversity racial diversity
but not intellectual diversity and I
think that's been really costly and I
think just some of the ways you're
suggesting it it breeds among other
things an incredible intellectual
complacency and I think in that in the
sense that for example viewpoints that
conservatives might voice come under
tremendous critical scrutiny are really
questioned or really raked over the
coals and you know often presumptively
rejected as illegitimate or unpersuasive
whereas a lot of assumptions held by
people on the set on the American Left
go unexamined and for long periods and
in that's the kind of intellectual
environment in which error can thrive in
which orthodoxies can gel and in which
your rights in which viewpoints can
become instead of diverse they can end
up becoming homogenized and there's a
real danger that that's what's happening
not in the sense that all people on the
Left agree with each other because on
campuses they don't in any academic
knows that but
orthodoxies and homogeneity in the sense
that they stop reflecting the true
diversity intellectually of the whole
country and that really is happening no
nicely put I'm glad that you're in that
environment and bring out if you know
what your political views are but you're
asking the right questions that I'm
grateful for that thank you professor